nous voulons savoir pourquoi il a fait ça et quel
est le prix à payer quand
on le fait, c'était une personne qui a créé
une grande quantité d'atrocités
[Musique]
et cela nous a donné l'occasion de
voir Pablo Escobar  sur une courte distance
mais aussi pour le voir de l'extérieur 3
puisqu'elle était journaliste et j'ai un
paysage de ce qu'il a créé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique] [Musique
] [
Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[  Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où il montre à quel point un
être humain horrible était mais aussi pourquoi une personne
comme lui a été créée parce que nous sommes
responsables de créer quelqu'un comme
celui-ci